hey guys it is the second of September
today my name is Jess McDonald and
today's edition of gamespot news
features the phrase hibernating babies
so stick around for that there was some
murmuring toward the end of last week
that maybe we weren't going to see GTA 5
come to PC after all but apparently this
isn't the case rockstar has promised
that the PC Edition has not been canned
or delayed and that it's still on track
to hit shelves in the wall alongside
versions for the xbox one and ps4 as for
something a little more specific than
one of the four quarters of the year an
unofficial listing at UK game
distributor exert us gem has suggested
that the ps4 edition is coming on
November 14 gaming news site VG 24-7 has
also reported that internal sources
suggest November is the most watch for
the release date last week 1 G was
telling us that destiny is going to be
pretty damn long and now apparently it's
also quite difficult well at least the
raids will be bungee design lead Luke
Smith has said that taking advantage of
the six player co-op is crucial in
destiny and that it's dangerous to go
alone alright he didn't say that exactly
but he should have what he did say is
that group of six is trying to form a
metaphorical key which opens a given
encounters lock by design we don't
provide much in the way of information
to groups in raids there aren't
waypoints to follow or objectives
explaining what to do in a given
situation realistically for many players
they'll be turning to the internet for
help on how to do a bunch of the raid
Smith said they're fully embracing the
possibility that players will have to
look up online walkthroughs once you
finish an encounter on normal you'll
have the option to try out the game
second difficulty rating the ambiguously
named hard where the enemies are tougher
and the penalties for death are more
harsh as for how long you can take to
complete a raid you'll get a week for
each before your progress is wiped Sims
4 has a day one patch set to resolve all
kinds of typical sim related issues like
babies living in your inventory and the
struggle of trying to maintain a
relationship with the Grim Reaper yo
no longer even be able to go on a first
date with the tall dark and bony Grim
Reaper but luckily EA have pics an issue
with hibernating babies living in
household inventories which is probably
important most of the changes include
preventing crashes and instating bug
fixes if you like reading you can catch
the full list on site ask your question
of the day let me know if you like
looking up walkthroughs or if you tend
to avoid them if you want more news you
can head to gamespot and check out
stories on things like minecraft on xbox
one or Telltale's Game of Thrones that
is it for me and all the good stuff you
need to hear about today i'll be back
same time tomorrow so i hope to catch of
them